hello everyone thank you for watching
this indigenous wisdom is critical
for our planetary health and for our
collective prosperity
I was very fortunate to
attend a workshop of a native Colombian
elder mama knew we won
is the Colombian elder
this is part of the indian mounds the
Sierra Nevada de Santa Maria de Santa
Marta
Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta Mountains
in Colombia the the Kogi are the tribe
of about 20,000 native people indigenous
people of that part of the world and
they have for the last
thousand years been dealing with
colonialism people have been coming
attempting to colonize the indigenous
land that they live on they've been
there for a long time and they've slowly
been exposed to money now and they have
a lot of important wisdom to share about
our connection with our planet with our
connection with source with spirit with
that which is all that is from what we
originate from from this planet that
sustains us and that nourishes us I was
very fortunate to attend a workshop on
Monday this last week and learn
took a lots of notes and I will be
sharing those notes with you
we need to become better stewards of our
home our home is planet Earth we need to
become better stewards of our home
we have a connection with the divine
nature that word currently very
disconnected from the indigenous wisdom
says this relationship is an older
brother that is speaking to the
disconnect a younger brother the younger
brother can be thought of as the the
busy business people around the world
the tech everything people
we need to connect to nature as we also
build the future
without that connection to spirit
without taking care of our home that we
live in we are lacking the understanding
of the interconnectedness of where we
live and how we are in many ways our
home is burning down
we need to step out of the ordinary life
and step into this new space on a spirit
to spirit level and reconnect in a new
way with this presence of life
wisdom is being transmitted to us all
the time from nature all the time
when birds chirp that's wisdom being
communicated to us when we look at trees
that's wisdom being communicated to us
only take a big deep breath of air
that's wisdom being communicated to us
a sip of water
wisdom being communicated to us a little
bit of food wisdom communicated to us
the shower wisdom communicated to us
exercise wisdom communicated to us it's
all around us all the time
we need to tap into that spirit so we
can figure out how to be harmonious with
the home that we reside on which is
planet Earth
human race falls into the same mistake
over and over again
the disconnection from nature and then
plane in this immature spiritual way
with technology of the gods and then the
civilization collapses happen many times
before and will be next if we don't
connect back with nature
we are exterminating nature
and it may be difficult to feel when we
are in a home in suburbia with green
grass and trees but we are exterminating
nature in so many ways around our planet
we're not respecting the
interconnectedness of the ecosystems
when we impact and mine plunder the
earth for resources for all of the
fossil fuels that we use for all of the
pollution this is interconnected it
affects the water cycle it effects all
of the natural cyclical patterns on our
planet
all the organisms that live here the
extinction of them
the unsustainable ways that we're
progressing
on Monday for the first part I was the
only guy in attendance in a room with 20
other women and mom and Louie one is a
is a man that was very frightening to me
and those that are watching that our men
should realize why it's frightening I
know the women realize why it's
frightening
guys we need to connect to spirit more
we need to connect to nature more so
many of the men are running so many of
the corporations and governments around
the world we more than anyone need to
connect to nature fast
and our origins are obfuscated where we
come from nature and spirit but there
Optive skated mass media is keeping us
numb
there's so much noise we need to find
the signal
the signal comes from the process of
conscious connection to nature
there's nowhere to move on to this is
our planet we have to become better
stewards of our planet
we can't keep destroying the space we
live in the government doesn't solve
this
we've created this problem
and we're inventing second-order
solutions to solve the problem but the
first order most principled solutions
are within us we are the divine
creatures the divine beings
that were given life on the rock on
earth and we get to connect back to that
system that gives us nourishment our
planet
don't be manipulated don't be deceived
don't be manipulated to see this
specially by all of the noise it's
keeping us numb find the signal
and we can very easily see all of the
advertisements that are keeping us numb
by this it'll make you happy no we know
that
if to embody that and live it and
practice it
and I went with a friend on Monday and
she had said the night before that I can
just look it up on the internet I can
look up this tribe and this experience
of it understanding indigenous wisdom on
the Internet
and that's when I replied no you can't
look at the internet and have an
embodied experience understanding
indigenous wisdom being communicated to
you by a spiritual leader of our planet
when we do what's right this conscious
connection in nature all of the BS will
collapse
what sustains us is being manipulated by
those in power were mesmerised by our
technology devices
the real information has kept away from
us so we don't panic the lack of that
conscious connection to nature
and the manipulation the exploitation
and the deception are benefiting a
select few
the collective doctor of the human race
is saying we have cancer if I'm in
America if you want to know the truth
follow the money
face those facts
younger brother has to recover and deal
with this reality the reality that we
need to consciously connect back to
nature
humanity needs more active conscious
people reality that we have is reflected
in nature everyday everyday we see a
civilization that has so many issues the
mental health crisis so much trauma
it's a direct reflection of our
disconnection from nature
humans like comfort we need to invest in
maintaining comfort our planetary health
nature will make humans pay
earth is buried with lost civilizations
that manipulated and harnessed power
until nature completely exterminated
them if we're not conscious about the
power we're going to be exterminated
people are absorbed in manic programming
in screens in cities ignoring the
biologic reality around us
we are not different from nature
there's so few water systems on the
planet that are unhide jacked and
unaffected by humans
natural resources of the earth are not
to be mined for money it will take a
long time to repair the water systems in
the forests on the planet we won't see
it it will only come many generations
later our house is burning we have to
stop damaging the ecology
to stop building artificial worlds these
cities that we live in this is not the
ideal design of a city a big concrete
jungle is not the ideal design of a city
the nature works just like our body when
our body has an issue
our body needs to heal that ailment
nature right now has deep issues and we
need to heal those otherwise our body
dies otherwise nature will die
and we know that in just a decade two
decades we're gonna have a billion or
more people on the planet more people
consuming earth we need conscious awake
people that are connected to earth that
are connected to nature
I wrote that this is a hard simulation
this is hard there's not that many
people that are consciously connected to
spirit and they're really trying to
scurry and find each other around the
world and help awaken others to connect
so that we can have a home that isn't
burned down fertility is being targeted
so that people don't reproduce a
mandatory suppression of reproduction in
certain parts of the world Africa's
population is booming China and India
have 1.4 billion people each China
prevented 400 million births over thirty
five years humans are treating nature
like a fridge open it take whatever we
want
and close the door and when it's empty
we buy more when it's empty we buy more
we buy more we buy more and then what
you can think of the materials that we
use that we just bury back into the
earth as slowly the plundering of
resources from the earth as slowly
bringing the health bar of the earth
down and then the garbage that we you do
landfills with that is in the Pacific
Ocean to the health bar of the earth
decreasing
humans transmit energy love stewardship
to nature and it heals
we need nature to be as pristine as it
can be follow the voice of nature fix
our mistakes before nature comes after
us in the blink of an eye
and then the civilization collapses
prevent that
most of us are in this playground earth
a big amusement park with our
distractions being deceived manipulated
not consciously connected to our planet
and most civilizations have collapsed
because they've invaded and intruded the
sacred space of nature we need to go to
sacred places and analyze what nature is
saying
prevent this collapse locally and
collectively and specifically here in
California in Silicon Valley we can be
better stewards you're come here to
Silicon Valley and we had and we're not
consciously going to the Pacific Ocean
which is right next to us
we're not consciously connecting to the
sacred space of this area we're just
stacked in the boxes typing on keyboard
unconsciously we can do better in LA to
LA to the media scene there the ability
to disseminate really powerful memes
around conscious connection to spirit in
nature this is not being done right now
we have the power in Silicon Valley in
Los Angeles to do a lot California needs
to awaken
we need to allow nature to tune us to
tune us that's what we feel when we
breathe and are grateful for the breath
when we drink the water great for the
water when we're around two trees in the
oceans on our planet on the grass laying
and they're absorbing the sunlight we're
letting nature tune us
need to harmonize ourselves with the
spirited nature of the space that we
live in
when you go on a walk get out of your
head
humans have a pristine part of ourselves
that belongs with nature this is like
our grandmother like our mother our
heart belongs with the source of our
life our heart belongs with the source
that gives us life
zero knowing and agenda and expectations
just purity in nature let nature tune
you
recover this attunement
connect with the ocean the Sun that
trees pristinely with spirit without an
agenda
we are so connected toward the celestial
bodies as well we have so much to still
discover about the location of the
celestial bodies when we are birthed
into the world we're first conceived in
the woman and then when we are birthed
into the world we have so little
knowledge of what's happening still we
have a lot to still learn about that and
when we're born into the world in the
exact home town the sacred location of
our birthplace how connected are we to
that sacred location of our birthplace
we have to connect to the nature of our
birthplace into the nature of this
journey
nature is a spirit a lifeforce humans
are supposed to be wise peak
collaborators but we are distorted we
need to help champion self and
collective realization with nature
nature needs to read us as benign beings
not as cancerous beings that are
plundering the planet that are
ambivalent unknowing and unresponsive to
the interconnected mayhem that we are
causing we need to apologize mother I
love you I'm sorry
you need to apologize for the mistakes
we've made all of us about the
interconnected the lack of
interconnectedness the lack of
connectedness to nature
this is like paying the taxes that we
owe
reconciling the debts that we have with
nature the feeling of emotionally
melting when we connect with nature
journaling sharing our experiences just
like we care about our technology we
need to share just like we care about
nature
I mean you care about earth this is an
individual experience not to postpone
then get others to experience it need to
master the art of harmonizing with
nature
this is good questions to ask people
where were you born where do you get
your air from where do you get your
water from where do you get your food
from the answers
earth earth sustains us it nourishes us
and we're disconnected from the life
that it gives us disconnected from the
interconnectedness the earth is visibly
sick we need to become better stewards
and work on ourselves
tuned to nature we develop our light
practice as a spirit connect as a
conscious spirit reconcile with what
sustains us so many ways we are addicted
to information and right now you're
watching this on an information stream
we're listening to it
finding the signal in the information
streams is so important and blocking out
the noise
though connect with spirit connect with
nature
and when we don't know ourselves and we
don't know this mother spirit we become
addicted to mechanical consumption like
zombies
experiencing life directly has been
stolen by this deceptive system
celebration of life is the communion
with the Spirit of nature
and if you follow the path of society in
many ways you'll become a psychopath
everyone can do this everyone can
commune everyone can connect with nature
in the Kohi
this in native indigenous tribe in
Colombia in the Sierra Nevada de Santa
Marta mounds Indian indigenous tribe is
being commoditized the Kogi's they're
now using money buying things
disconnecting from spirit this is
happening to Native people around the
world to indigenous tribes around the
world they're the last holders of the
real indigenous wisdom the connection
watching Aluna their documentary is so
profound so important
do incredible things like the ones that
are spiritually connected the greatest
the Mamas identify the women that are
having another mama another child that's
going to grow up into a mama and the
child grows up in the cave from 0 to 9
years old and doesn't take in any light
just is in the darkness connecting to
earth for nine years then they enter
into the light it's things like that
that really make you think why do they
do that and the mother is there to with
the child and so is the mama working
with the child as they grow up until
they're 9 why why do they do that what
can be gained from nine years of
connecting to earth before going on into
it what do you think
I think a lot
I feel a lot can be understood way
deeper than what we understand
we're moving from the triangle to the
circle from the hierarchy to the
decentralized circle from the meat of
the we everyone wins and earth is saved
get away from being the mental Iser this
is not spiritual this takes resources
build skyscrapers run businesses this
type of thinking
we need to put it into action work an
experiential connection to spirit versus
this mental insanity non-stop there's no
balance of spirit everybody knows it but
isn't applying it
those that are knowledge maniacs apply
it we need to learn spirit first hand
challenge ourselves and share our
practice information manipulation and
deception is creating noise and a thirst
for this inclusive fitness of mom of
spirit and source of the
interconnectedness
why are we so disconnected from these
basic things our origins are being
obfuscated born into these artificial
cities no stars no farms money is the
number one thing the old code is staying
in motion we need to make the new code
and it starts with our conscious
connection recovering our sacred
connection in nature nature will tell
you the truth our origins not the
internet nature is a history keeper a
blockchain
protect the land with wisdom not with
war rediscover sacred sites go on sacred
pilgrimages visit our sacred grandmother
that we've abused
bring conscious and benign energy to
earth have a conscious spiritual
education treat water like it's a
conscious beautiful process we need to
have a deeper intent of connection to
water food air consciously connecting
each moment and we need to understand
that we've been colonizing land of
indigenous people
punishment is coming we need to repay
our taxes our delinquencies we need to
revisit the delinquencies and be honest
with ourselves
consciously connect to nature
every moment we can consciously connect
with nature with spirit even with even
what that inhales and exhales we need to
re-engage with our sacred space has
fixed the water cycles fix these issues
on the planet
bring the planetary health back up and
these sacred spaces are not just a place
for selfies I just go there take a
selfie and leave this is a place for
conscious connection deep spiritual
conscious connection to the sacred sites
the living original vision for the earth
love living original vision for the
earth the earth works 24/7 to keep us
alive
near pay taxes to nature be grateful for
the source of life activate these sacred
sites big things are transmitted to you
in darkness
silence conscious fusion with the
universe
younger brother is wanting to do this
and that and this plunder the resources
go and build things but the mother says
don't violate the rules the older
brother don't violate the rules
we're overwhelming nature too much the
younger brother is we can't violate the
rules of losing our connection from
nature that's why we have all the issues
with our civilization
we need to align ourselves with their
spirits full purpose
time is ticking what did we come here to
do endogenous motivation channeling
through us to build a better world to
connect to nature and build a better
world versus the exogenous motivation of
the materialistic possessions
wisdom and spirit versus ego and fantasy
if you go to the ego in fantasy expect
delays
do not prolong or postpone our
connection to spirit get it done how do
you carry yourself through the tough
parts of the journey
in many ways right now we live in a
schizophrenic hyper reality a worldview
that is these cities and these did this
deacon this this disconnection from
nature is real but it's not it's not
real it's a complete hyper reality of
the way that we sell our time for money
in order to live in these boxes stacked
on top of each other using the
technology devices and news feats that
have quantum computers trained on
billions of psychometric profiles that
are pointed at our faces all the time
that are sucking our souls away
the evil spirit is coming through that
void when we're not consciously
connected to nature evil spirit comes in
it fills that we're giving it a space
we're giving evil a space inside of us
inside of our world we need to
strengthen our spirit to combat the
negative spirit when you link with
negative spirits you give them room to
move in
many people are cornered or suppressed
or oppressed or limited so they try to
break through by harsh means this
unearned wisdom can cause difficulties
most people aren't wise enough to hold
space or elements of power are you
getting a crap or a craft experience
real shamans and spiritual leaders they
don't mess around
they don't play with these sacred spaces
and elements of power
master the use in the management of
technology younger brother otherwise
those a disaster looming
we dragged spirits in based on our
degree of connectedness to nature
what you need spiritually speaking is
within yourself
we need to recover and handle power
properly that's a massive challenge when
we're captivated by toys and deception
turn the other way imagine it as a do
not enter sign in your newsfeed do not
enter
turn around go the other way
don't miss your exits on your journey to
your Northstar to where you find most
meaning and purpose in the life these
are the greatest connections to
activating our connection to all that is
to spirit don't make the same mistakes
as previous lost collapse civilizations
that couldn't harmonize with nature
and again us in California and Silicon
Valley in LA we need to reconcile with
nature the oceans next door we can help
solve these pressing challenges
so that was from Monday from the longer
workshop on Monday and then just
yesterday Thursday
I did not attend an event that had a lot
of other people that I know attending at
night to attend another event where mama
knew we you one was speaking at the
Center in San Francisco
and this was just an evening
and it was Q&A from the
attendees
and I think it was actually really
important for all of those that were
attending the other event for them all
to have actually been listening to mama
so the question question was about
accumulation of power and mama keeps
bringing all of the answers back to
spirit back to nature back to our
disconnection back to our need to
connect to it mama taught about the
Earth's rules mother's rules and
nature's rules and we how we can't screw
around with it
we're supposed to harmonize and
co-create play within the rules within
the checks and balances of nature and
we're overindulging in the creation
having a lost sense of our own being and
our own agreements with nature we need
to constantly check in with mother with
spirit as daughters and sons we have
fallen from grace we're messing with
extraordinary sources of power in
previous civilizations has collapsed
from doing this with immaturity
when you mess with mother in the cosmos
you get destroyed
you need to obey the rules of nature we
need to use power to maintain balance
and harmony and co-create not go to war
and manipulate we need to generate life
power has become a fixation for
validation don't rule anyone greed has
poisoned men's souls
power seekers tried disconnecting from
nature
if spirit is aligned power is good
don't fall into the same loop of the
same stupidity we have to become aware
of the burning house that is our planet
positive powers creative negative powers
destructive get out of the games of
control and manipulation and deception
understand the original wisdom of the
universe
another question how do i heal the
planet
every human needs to care and maintain
the system that takes care of us
we have privileges and responsibilities
we stop the immense negative global
impact we are calling for doomsday
we need to recover the consciousness we
are responsible for the system that
sustains us governments are busy with
their own agendas they don't care greedy
people corrupt people we are responsible
for the system that sustains us tune
yourself to the positive power of Mother
the sheer amount of global chaos we have
right now is causing deception massive
collective chaos seven plus billion
people don't know how to function with
nature
that says everything about the issues we
have in civilization
we're here to master experience in this
realm we have disconnected escapist
tendencies our mental disorders are a
reflection of our disconnection from
nature
another question how do we connect a
spirit better there's so much deception
tune yourself conscious connection to
nature who you are in the most serious
deception of spiritual things that
hamper block use or take over our spirit
evil is in the business of captivating
Souls spirits have power that evil
doesn't have our Spirit is superior to
the deception but it's up to us
it's up to us which company we aligned
with in spirit watch out and reminder
about these transmissions that when mom
is talking to the group it is on fire
that signal is on fire and I'm doing my
best right now to communicate from that
through these notes to you that is
viewing right now
our tech is a reflection of our
spiritual connection the issues that we
have with tech are a reflection of our
spiritual connection when spirit births
it craves universe's wisdom art and
science need to be in tune with
spirituality spirit in the blink can go
anywhere in the universe
technology is dangerous like Europeans
that came and wiped the natives who were
freaks playing with toys that violate
the rules of nature in this dimension
it's a recipe for disaster
another question what is good tech same
as using your body the body is a tuning
piece for higher levels of consciousness
we are science tech and art spirit
me be careful people will be robots
completely controlled by dark powers the
natural laws functioning with spirit
we are dysfunctional with the spirit
that sustains us animals have spirit
they have a crucial role in nature a
harmonious role with humans in nature
and if we don't know the function of
creatures in the interconnectedness it's
a big problem lots of species now have
been extincted by humans especially in
the last hundred years and we don't
understand the interconnectedness and
we're wiping them out we will be next
just like if we don't drink water we die
similarly animals have a role in
function in the ecosystems that we live
in
deception has taken too much power
and this is interesting from the tech
industry angle that in many ways satoshi
nakamoto anonymously as that deception
took so much power with the misaligned
incentives of self dealing in our world
and disconnection from nature boom
Satoshi Nakamoto brought anonymously the
technology of blockchain into our world
this spiritual update was delivered
anonymously very interesting maybe this
method needs to be practiced more
the deploying the spiritual updates into
civilization anonymously
we're in a race to enlighten the younger
brother to have the younger brother
connect with spirit
machines come with instructions and
we've been told how to function in this
dimension this environment but we're not
applying it it's comical our loss of
common sense again what sustains us is
this planet is nature
if you discover you're not full with the
spirit it means you're being deceived
don't be deceived
level the first level of deception is
the disconnection from the original
spiritual wisdom that's when we have a
lack of clarity a lack of purpose but we
need this natural living life you are
spirit first your body is the vessel
spirits follow a very clear purpose and
if you're not following your purpose
then you're being deceived and for those
that are wondering well what does
someone like a mama what do they eat and
drink well they nourish themselves with
mother they don't harm nature they're
pro-life what do they drink they drink
water
they don't drink too much water that
debilitates them but it were overflows
them but they don't also stay to dry
either
I asked also about money as well because
we live in the civilization that
requires us to sell our time for money
in order to be able to live for pay for
our rent to pay for food these types of
things the momma said as soon as you pay
your taxes to nature your rent to nature
that things come into motion so we need
to pay our taxes to nature we have a big
bill that's coming civilization you can
see the big bill of the seven plus
billion people disconnected you can see
it coming
it's painful when we shared this wisdom
of nature and then doesn't resonate with
certain people but it does resonate with
others and hopefully this catalyzes you
to go and consciously connect to nature
on a moment-to-moment basis when Spirit
has issues we have to do work to clear
it the divine father and mother are one
in the same the father conceives in the
mother delivers one unified power only
one when spirit is aligned we can
manifest much more energetically we need
to pay our taxes to nature to manifest
money to manifest what we need for
nourishment
bring forth spirit act with spirit not
with the head the mental Iser is
expecting controlling but spiritual
science and technology the art of being
here in being functional what is a good
life connection to nature to what
sustains us the power of deception is
creating more chaos disconnecting us
further from spirit we can come together
correcting our behavior according to the
rules of nature deception will do
whatever it takes malevolent spirits
trying to control the human race we are
not here to battle deception we are here
to function intelligently deception
wants to keep you in battle obey the
natural law retune our spirits with the
power of the cosmos deception wants you
to battle so you become the loser
consciously connect to spirit and we win
we are meant to live and die not be
fearful function with God daily a deep
conscious love not to be deceived
and a counter to some of the leading
arguments today of this is the best time
to be alive well really we are at a
katha catastrophic moment that it is we
have now so many megalomaniacs and so
much so much psychopathy and neurosis
and civilization of people disconnected
from source spirit nature that were
playing with godlike technology that the
people of our past the hundred billion
humans of our past were actually more
connected to spirit when they spent
their time in villages with trees with
animals with plants actually growing
gathering their food we were more
consciously connected to spirit be
conscious first then generate love the
last hundred years we didn't consciously
take control so deception did master
achieve fulfilled the purpose of life
don't battle deception to recover the
sense of spirit this has been the fall
from grace the great deception when
people spontaneously recover their sense
of spirit they get targeted as weird I
got so many messages from people asking
me are you okay are you tripping
no I'm not I'm connecting deeply to
nature more and more awake to real
connection to nature to the truth of
that and sharing it with others that
also see it and that are working on
themselves to
presidents don't really have power they
struggle for power real powers conscious
spiritual connection bring ancestral
original ancestral wisdom recover our
sense of spirit and function like it I
don't want to be president I want to
help people consciously connect to
spirit practice connecting to spirit to
self work recover the essence of spirit
the being with spirit shut up the sense
of knowing be with spirit manifest it
more make it more self evident and tap
into your sacred space of birth
massive power to fulfill the purpose of
life the beginning defines the journey
and ending pay the taxes right now a
moment more and pay the taxes also pay
the taxes to our sacred birth space for
all those in California mama Luigi
Juan's doing workshop for the entire
month of June in 2019 in Ojai in Santa
Barbara so do check that out
nature isn't conspiring against you it's
orchestrating for you
always bring the convo back to spirit
always bring the convo back to spirit
younger brother needs to wake up needs
to connect with nature
disobey the rules that have been laid
out by younger brother and align with
the divine rule don't make space for the
evil spirits to come through
that's all
thank you for watching for listening and
we know what to do it's within us all
the divine connection to nature to what
sustains us this indigenous wisdom we're
so blessed to have people like mom and
we Jiwon like the Kogi still in Colombia
were so lucky to still have them we need
to cherish the indigenous wisdom on the
planet
we need to actively consciously connect
to nature
don't fall for the deceptions don't let
people exploit you
think critically about the civilization
that we live in and how it's a direct
mirror of our disconnection from nature
what would civilization look like if we
were all connected to nature
you know what to do go and connect
moment to moment as our air our food our
water our shower with the trees the
plants the animals lay in the grass
absorb the sunlight really feel it feel
it feel how it sustains you connect with
nature and we can more easily prosper
together thank you